jacques chirac de son côté se rendre à
la synagogue de la rue en selle à
neuilly sur seine
cet engagement particulier des
principaux leaders politiques français
montrent que cette affaire les mobilise
dans l'indignation de la droite à la
gauche
on semble choqué par ce qui s'est passé
hier est parce que cette profanation
révèle de la société française de
l'intolérance dans notre pays depuis une
dizaine d'année oblige tous les uns
politiques à s'interroger sur leur
propre responsabilité
ont-ils toujours fait tout ce qui était
nécessaire pour empêcher le
développement de ce fléau
ce n'est pas aujourd'hui que
j'apporterai une réponse ce n'est pas le
moment et je ferai à ce sujet les
commentaires et des propositions et
d'autre part je veux dire que toutes les
françaises tous les français et je pense
plus particulièrement aux jeunes qui
font la société de demain doivent se
considérer comme d'abord obliger à une
grande vigilance mais aussi comme en
charge du retour nécessaire à l'esprit
de tolérance à l'esprit de fraternité
sans lesquels il n'y a pas de paix
civile
il n'y a pas de démocratie la de la
condamnation qui je l'espère fera pas un
jour les coupables lorsque la justice
aura pu se saisir 2 et à la condamnation
a porté sur tout ce qui contribue à ce
climat de haine qui y contribue en
particulier par des déclarations
racistes antisémites d'intolérance et
qui crée une banalisation de quelque
chose qu'on ne doit plus voir dans le
monde qu'on ne veut plus voir en france
nous avons connu hélas pendant la guerre
à une époque où il y avait même des lois
anti juives
nous voulons plus voir ça ni dans la loi
ni dans la politique ni dans la
en réalité de notre pays dans le monde
et pour cela il faut combattre le
racisme et ceux qui expriment des idées
qui conduisent à de tels actes